let's jump to this next Story another
reason why they don't like US Air Force
gender inclusive training tells Cadets
to not use Mom and Dad well I'm
confident we're going to defeat Russia
in this upcoming world war three how
about you guys well I mean that's what
I'm thinking is that you look back to
World War II you know the Battle of the
Bulge you've had these like massive tank
battles there had to have been a time
when you know before a shot is fired
everyone hops out of the tanks and says
okay what are your correct pronouns
that's how it works I remember that on d
uh I watched an old uh War documentary
about D-Day and actually before they
even fought the the U-boats land
everybody walks out peacefully shakes
hands and the Americans ask the Germans
their pronouns they all agreed that they
went back in the boats backed up and
then stormed the beach
100 I mean I I have to be honest like if
if the reality of future warfare was
arguments I'd be okay with that I'd
prefer that actually because you know
War sucks and so if like boats crash
land on the beach and they run out and
they're carrying like you know plushies
and then they run up to each other and
they're like you smell you smell dude
and that's like all war was I think
that's an improvement honestly like at
this point I think something that you
know we've seen from the past 20 years
when it was the US engaged in the global
war on terror and then
um I I think the Syrian conflict was a
great example is you're seeing less and
less of uh you know large World actors
the United States major Powers China
trying to engage in actual like open
Warfare right they'll they'll they'll
fund aside they'll arm aside but they
don't want to necessarily get entangled
in the conflict themselves like uh I
think prime example is you bring up a
China and Taiwan people like oh my God
when's China gonna like have their ships
hit the hit the beaches of Taiwan and
storm it and well I mean I think China's
it's become pretty clear to them that we
can just strangle countries at this
point with economic might you know like
what's the need to have to invade
America when we can use Amazon to make
this country dependent on us yeah
Amazon's the creepiest thing ever it's
incredible if if you were going to come
to me and and talk about some kind of
nightmare dystopian future and then
tried claiming the neural link and all
that stuff and I bet yeah yeah you know
maybe who knows but if you come to me
and tell me that you know if a guy came
to me and said he was from the future a
nightmare dystopia with Terminators and
everything and they're all run by Amazon
I bet yeah it makes sense yeah you know
because Amazon's a creepy company just
that it's just the control they have the
way they're destroying mom and pop shops
and small businesses we really are
moving towards this world where
I don't know how to describe it
techno-communism yeah you maybe just
want to describe it you're you're going
to get Ubi from the government you're
going to go on Amazon and you're going
to you you have eight you have 1800
credits per per month to select an item
it's like I believe I'll choose this
blue well that's the thing is like when
Yang ran on the on the Ubi thing you
know what I'm surprised more people
didn't question is okay if you create
this dependence on making sure that like
okay I will get this you know Dole from
the government the next step for them
then becomes what if you do something
that displeases me you know what if your
social score or social credit score goes
down right we're going to cut how much
money you get and you're gonna have to
be hungry and maybe that'll teach you a
lesson of what happens when you don't
follow the regime's orders yeah it's
it's a carbon social credit score it's
what the world economic forum is talking
about they literally just wrote in an
article bragging about how everyone
complied with the lockdowns which means
the next climate change lockdowns are
more likely to be complied with as well
that's literally did you see a lot of
these people did you see the the the
power companies I think it was in Nevada
maybe California as well that was
sending notifications during the
blackouts and and the heat waves that
they were sending out notifications on
the thermostat smart thermostats in
people's houses saying I'm sorry but you
can't turn down this was uh Denver I
believe yeah and it was because they
opted into a pro like an energy program
yeah that's how it all starts that's
right and that's the thing is just opt
into the government program will help
take care of you no but but what happens
is you're getting it installed and the
guy goes would you like to opt into our
energy saver program what is what does
that mean means you get 100 bucks per
year off your bill they go sign me up
and they scroll through the terms of
service they don't read and they click
check and then next thing they know they
can't turn the air conditioning on and
the thing is that when they said that
amount they're like okay it'll take 100
off or 20 months I can't remember how
much they offered uh for these people to
join the energy saver program who's
gonna be the most incentivized to opt in
for people right really well I mean you
think I'm gonna give up my exactly the
pores yeah
a rump
that's how they live man they want their
private jets I like all the private jets
flying into the climate change Summit
yeah yeah the real meeting is them going
like how do we keep this going we gotta
stop the poor people that's exactly it
the four people don't deserve
refrigerators or or clean water or
showers y'all can have cold crickets and
cold showers because I ain't giving up
my steak I imagine that's what Bill
Gates is saying and I mean like I've
always said is that to a certain extent
they want to say you have to eat the
bugs not because it's ecologically sound
but because they'd like to be able to
show their power like you can make your
enemies or your subordinates eat bugs
it's like what won't it's like the poop
order they want you to drink the poop
orders or the sewage water and there was
an article did you guys see California
is going to allow composting of humans
no the funny thing is yeah it's terrific
into soil now hold on hold on it's not
immediately bad but there are some
concerns the idea is that you can be
cremated you can be embalmed or whatever
or you can be dropped into this vat you
know of dirt and every you get turned
into dirt right it doesn't immediately
mean they're going to use the dirt for
food the soil I should say because it's
going to be fresh human compost soil in
I think Colorado I'm not sure they ban
the sale of this soil for uh food for
human consumption but questions then are
is the soil being transferred to farms
for grain for cow consumption right to
what degree are you okay with eating
former human like is it if a corn grows
from the human is then eaten by a pig
are you okay eating that I've seen The
Lion King uh the circle of life I know
how this story ends we will be eating
the human soil that's right we will yeah
yeah it's only a matter of time
especially with the food shortages and
everything going on Soylent Green is
people man have you guys seen that movie
Elysium no I didn't see that no it's
like I think it's Matt Damon yeah and
it's like everyone there's like a
utopian like layer and then they're yeah
and all the rich people live up there
and then like they have the cure for
cancer and the poor people lived on
earth they all speak Spanish and the
rich people speak French I thought it
was kind of funny they got it wrong
though what's what's really what it
really should have been is all the poor
people on Earth working eating crickets
and everyone up in the Big Ring are
trafficking children
[Laughter]
you know what they do and I wonder if
one of the reasons they want to shut
down like channels like this is because
we will call them out and they're
probably thinking imagine what we could
get away with I actually uh here's what
I think happens you get it's like
imagine it's 10 years ago
and Epstein's on his Island sitting
there smoking a cigar next to his
picture of Bill Clinton address and
there's like this 18 year old kid who's
in he's a newbie in the whole
trafficking kids thing you know a new
recruit and he goes
you know kid before the internet nobody
knew we were doing this
now it's like I had to have a running
with the FBI then 2020 comes along this
kid's now you know a bit older and he's
like man what how much fun how cool
would it have been back in the 60s when
no one knew you were committing
atrocities against children right I
think these people know this and they're
and they're really talking about like
when we were younger nobody knew we were
doing it no journalist was allowed on
the island anybody who tried to write
about would be ridiculed or we would
simply go to the boss of the company and
say do not write it and they would look
at ABC news with that Amy rorbach woman
yep she said we had this guy dead or
it's like and Clinton and here's the
thing that's why they don't like project
Veritas oh yeah I was talking to a guy
and and I passively bring up Veritas he
goes ah but they're they're all lying
you know and then I was like what do you
lied about and he was like well I don't
know I read somewhere and I'm like no
I'll tell you what James O'Keefe got
leaked this video exposing Epstein and
boy were they pissed so I'm willing to
bet they pulled out all the stops of
their billions of dollars trying to fame
that guy and he was like well all and I
was like do you think these Elite petos
who are private islands you think they
wouldn't spend at least a million
dollars lying about somebody and he's
like well
oh yeah I don't know or covering up
their traces and their tracks uh Bill
Gates literally funds the corporate
media he gives hundreds of millions of
dollars to many corporate media outlets
and of course this buys him favor this
buys him PR this buys him marketing and
and this is why Jeff his business Jeff
Bezos owns the Washington Post Yeah and
when uh Bill Gates was asked about apps
needles well he's dead now anyway what
did he say is that what he said
something like that something like that
yep yep it doesn't matter he's dead at
this point at this point why does it
even matter you know the quote he was
like well he's dead so yeah he looks
over at Hillary and she's like I did my
job
someone needs to do a compilation of
those two videos
yeah send it to me please immediately on
Twitter I may hire you at Luke we are
change uh but look it's a fun it's a fun
ride while it lasts I suppose the the
October surprise whatever it's going to
be they need to stop shows like this
from being able to call it out you know
whatever they end up doing with with
framing Maga or Trump or whatever
we had a guy in North Dakota just kill a
kid a teenager you know I'll call him a
kid who's 18 years old ran him down ran
him over he was drunk too this guy was
charged with the DUI he was over the
legal limit hit this kid and then
claimed the kid was threatening him I'm
like oh the 18 year old kid was
threatening you and your SUV when you
ran him down sure bro you could have
left so they don't like when we call
that out because they want the narrative
to be like the FBI whistleblowers are
pointing out that it's a bunch of Maga
extremists but the reality is we got
anti-fun BLM who've destroyed cities
across this country a couple years ago
and like yeah there are some creepy
weirdo right-wingers that and and
there's some really extreme stuff that's
happening around the world but the
overall Terror and high numbers comes
from the left hands down and they're
desperately trying to lie about it and
they play dirty games like the ADL
claims that like so we're saying if
you're anti-government you're right wing
and it's like so like an anti-fuck
streamists could be like I'm
anti-government they go well he's a he's
a right-wing anti-government guy and
it's like bro the guy's got a communist
tattoo on it not he's anti-government
anti-government is right wing I mean
it's something how we had a summer in
this country where in the 30 largest
cities in in this nation you had
synchronized riots
synchronized riots right and then New
York State's a perfect example where
they just blanket pardoned everyone it's
like oh what you set fire to a building
what you you destroyed people's homes
their businesses their livelihoods
there's a blanket pardon I mean it's
incredible it's incredible and the way
that it's like well I mean the riots the
voice of the unheard when it smokes on
artifact right I mean it's incredible
it's incredible and they bail them out
and they raise them all raises money to
be like well let's get them out and yet
recidivists you had people who got out
from there committed assault and rape
after Kamala called for like cash to be
sent just here's what you do next time
there's gonna be like a protest we just
need like 500 people to join antifa
no I mean it because it's all about it's
all about the mob right if there's going
to be like a hundred people at an antifa
thing and they're all wearing hoodies
and stuff and then we're like okay we'll
get 500 people those 500 people can be
like we vote not to throw the brick then
they're going to be like uh someone will
throw it and then the other end will be
like you're a fascist so basically you
like if you go in there and you're like
yeah I'm on board with this antifa thing
the moment you see someone trying to get
violent or doing whatever call him a
fascist being like hey let's play the
game too and then stop them from doing
it stop the violence stop the right stop
the the hurting of innocent people and I
don't know what are they going to do
about it then the media will be like
antifa stops violence within their own
race exactly as long as it's not
happening how responsible yeah you know
but fiery but mostly peaceful protests
yeah well they're like well their names
are anti-fascist guys that's right come
on yeah
you're the bad guys we're the good guys
we like good things you like bad things
that was Sheamus's bit shout out to
Sheamus oh yeah Sheamus because I think
his bit was that Democrats will be alike
we want good thing yeah we we want good
thing for everyone and then you'll go
okay well how do you pay for a good
thing you want bad thing yeah you want
bad things exactly well they're they're
all down dude it is very interesting
just I feel like it's just in like the
last five years maybe in the beginning
of trump it went from like we disagree
on policy to if you don't want this
policy you're for violence or you're
killing people oh look at Matt Walsh
he's like Matt Walsh comes out and he's
like Vanderbilt Medical Clinic is doing
surgeries on minors and then they go
you're trying to kill people that's the
thing is they they're down there they've
now become the first card that they pull
is that if you disagree with me people
will die you're advocating for violence
I'm just imagining like here's a bit for
you Sheamus if you're listening it can
be like the day a day in the life of a
left-wing activist and it's like hey
guys uh what do you want to get for
dinner I vote pizza I want wings well I
don't know if I want wings if you
disagree with me we'll die yeah it's
just like uh okay dude calm down you can
understand why there is so much
left-wing violence when they truly
believe those are the stakes right yep
and if those are the stakes and and you
know the the rest of this machine sort
of Stokes that fire
if they really believe those are the
stakes what's the end of that I mean
that wouldn't that wouldn't be worth it
this is it is as you you get you get a
left Winger to murder a kid right that's
this guy you get the Bernie Sanders
supporter gunning down those car makers
on the baseball diamond so you certainly
do have like creepy Ultra Ultra National
traditional traditionalists who have
committed atrocities for sure but what
you see of with with Tara from the left
is extended and what I refer to as like
blunt force or low tier right so you
know every couple of years or so you
might hear a story about some like
unhinged quote unquote right-winger guy
and what I mean by that is like probably
like an ultra traditionalist or
nationalist who will shoot a bunch of
people it's terrifying we don't we want
that to stop the FBI should be tracking
those people and stopping that's what
they should be doing but what you get
with the left is like on a daily basis
people getting punched in the head
shoved attacked uh Benny Johnson just
had his Podium kicked over by an
unhinged lunatic uh now it's starting to
get more serious where this guy AI North
Dakota Rams a kid and he was drunk and
I'm just imagining you know maybe it's
my bias but I'm imagining this guy is
seeing this kid and they're having a
dance party and he thought the kid was
part of a republican extremist group
like what is that even but the fact that
he even thought being a part of a
republican group made the kid extremist
in some way he was paranoid and
delusional and drunk and so he killed a
kid
that's that's that's
whatever you want to say it's getting
crazy around the president of his
country had just appeared on TV not too
long ago with this like horrific red
background saying that Republican
extremists are going to destroy
democracy right and then on a daily
basis he sees left Winger left-wing
groups left-wing individuals say if you
disagree with us that's violence like
don't you realize by by showing that
this group in Vanderbilt said that this
is a profitable Enterprise that people
are gonna die that like there's gonna be
death threats don't you realize that
disagreeing with me is violence they say
they say if Republicans get back in
power that democracy is over yeah if you
truly believe that what and what you
know what doesn't justify violence we're
not a democracy but if the Democrats
retain power the Republic is over that's
right thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there